when's your birthday
february 1st yeah aquarius aquarius okay
what's yours halloween halloween really
what is a good business partner
what does that make you scorpion ooh
why do you say them scorpios are fun
they're trouble but they're fun
[Music]
are you hard-headed no
how would you describe yourself um
loving humble
spontaneous naive at times
um
the hbic i'm hbic
head [ __ ] in charge oh is that right
that's the scorpio in you
all right queen queen oh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
i'm from north carolina
north carolina yeah um
i've been out here in l.a since january
well you're new in town
yeah i'm new don't know my way around
like that it's my first time over there
you've been here how many how many
months how many years
six months six months
tell me about your family you had both
mom and dad um
neither one of them raised me um
my mom walked out and i was 17. i have
two kids
i have two girls six and four are you
raising them
no they're back home i'm on my own
no family my kids are good but as far as
me
who are your kids with my god they're
god parents like you know
when you when you're pregnant you give
someone the rights of being a god parent
so if anything happens to you the god
parent is your child
so they're with their godparents they're
good
and how would you describe your
childhood um
dark alone sad i was raised pentecostal
so you couldn't cut your hair and wear
pants
makeup you know stuff like that so i
started wearing pants
freshman year high school were you
raised by a white family no my
people are black my but pentecostal is
usually white right
yeah my family they have money
but money doesn't make me happy
it's about love and me feeling
comfortable so
no family your
your childhood was do you have any
trauma or anything like that
yeah um i was getting molested for years
um yeah
a cousin a cousin uh he was making
giving oil
but i didn't lose my virginity until i
was 14. till my kids fought him
and prostitution started for you at what
point
two years ago i've been homeless two
years
but you would never know like some
some days all right but i try to keep
myself up
at all times i'm just staying at hotels
being out all night but as far as
selling [ __ ] like every day
i don't do that i was more into
making videos selling them getting cash
out real quick or i have regulars
right now like i have to get out there
[Music]
you live in a hotel now yeah something
like that just
night by night you just figure it out
yeah
did you have a pimp no
no pimp but i do have an addiction so
i get money yeah chill what is your drug
cocaine cocaine correct long has that
been going on
um
well my real addiction i used to smoke
crack
um i'm getting methamphetamine but to
stay off methamphetamine i
smoke so i've been trying to stay off of
it
i mean i felt that like the other day
but besides that like
it's more of i don't want it i really
let myself crash and go to sleep
but when i do want to be up and make
money i do
smoke keeps you up all night
yeah i've been up to this second day
and i ran into him i was about to take a
shower and put my outfit on
you find it's helpful to be drunk or
high or something just to do this kind
of work
yeah it'd be hard to do it straight
right
yeah i did last night it wasn't that bad
what kind of guys were you no
you're black men no black men
i've heard that a lot yeah it's over
i've been hurt too much
like mexicans um
i don't like when they don't speak any
english though because they're like too
rough
i don't like being i don't like being
around people or being touched like that
so i do let you around me
don't just rush into you know like take
your time a little bit and you'll get
the full effect of me but if you
rush it and you're trying to i'm not
going to be feeling it
and then you're gonna get a half-assed
job right now it's gonna be comfortable
drink a little bit yeah and then i'm
ready tell me about the guys that pick
you up
do you like them um it depends
right i'd rather be
i'd rather take videos and pictures than
just selling my personal style
i mean i'd rather go without money than
doing that
or i'll go get my [ __ ] from the store
and just take it before i just
have my thumb up so
i want to get into anal i haven't done
it since october
so i'm gonna plug and stuff but until
then i ain't been doing that
you can make more money doing that
probably yeah they ask a lot
what are sports but you got like you got
to be somebody cleaning out your regular
um you get asked to do things without a
condom
yeah um i got tested um
march 22nd 23rd i got the next one on in
my arm
my birth control i got everything done
the same day everything came back
negative
but since i've been out i have had
unprotected sex
so i'm going to be going to the doctor
and i'm going to set up an appointment
i'm trying to get the point set by
friday
at least be seen because i got raped um
four five days ago so
it wasn't like i'm like assault but
you know when when i was asleep so i'm
protected
but i keep up with myself as much as i
can
what emotions does this lifestyle
bring up people i'm sad sometimes i'm
happy sometimes i'm ready sometimes
i don't want to do it
does your family know you're doing it
who knows
i just mean my mom stopped talking like
seven years ago
um i talked to my family
almost a year and
this is your adopted family you're
talking about my real family oh your
real family
i'm on grandma's only granddaughter i'm
the only girl
what's the hardest part of doing this
kind of work for you um
not knowing if you don't come out of it
or not yeah it's dangerous right
what's the worst thing that you've seen
what's worse thing that's happened to
you
um on a date rape
and he beat the [ __ ] out of my head
while i was asleep he raped me
he tried to give me this sleeping pill
and
i didn't take it i put in my bra and
when i eventually got up
uh i went to the medicine cabinet
and it was like a sleeping pill and then
i woke up it was like four o'clock in
the morning i was in vegas
you know i got a ticket for like five
hours a 24-hour pass and i just got on
advice
when i go through [ __ ] i just go through
by myself take it as a loss because i
know i'm gonna see better days
but you're friends no
are you lonely i don't i don't trust
people i do like people around but they
show their true colors
it's like you'll flip for money you'll
flip for
fame but if you actually sit there
and hold me when i need you i got you
because i'm only 22. i will be a
billionaire
by the time i'm 45. i guarantee it
just out for help everything i want to
do like i want to have my own brand
like makeup clothes shoes purses
i want to be the queen pin of cocaine
like i really
want this but
how much were you making tonight
it's like three like two to three if i
do it
then it goes to cocaine
you know i'll be doing [ __ ] i'm already
out cocaine's your pimp
and do you have you feel guilt about
your kids or anything like that
no no they're good um i raised them
but i i was like look i need help so
they're helping me
my kids don't want female and my oldest
i have beautiful kids
i'm puerto rican oh i'm cherokee indian
ethiopian
and he's puerto rican dominican so my
kids are light
so they're beautiful long hand pretty
smiles big eyes
what was the worst part of your life
worst time of your life
last year vegas
just me i was trying to live right i
could have been selling [ __ ] out there
but i didn't know who was watching me
you know so i stopped everything i was
[ __ ]
at salvation armies every night i was
eating once a day at catholic charities
like at 10 a.m in the morning
i was eating that [ __ ] rescue
missions and [ __ ]
and i was practicing abstinence i got
into a mental health program and they
[ __ ] me
so it was like i was going through she
had to share the [ __ ] my birthday was
[ __ ]
october 31st thanksgiving was all right
christmas was [ __ ] new year's was [ __ ]
valentine's day i was asleep it was like
anytime it's a holiday coming out like i
missed it
yeah but what is life i mean
i could say that i want a relationship
but damn
is it bad to say that no one is good
enough for me no one deserves me
like i can give you me but as far as
me loving you no one deserves that for
me because they're gonna use me
take my kindness or weakness but i'm
really crazy like
i'm schizophrenic um bipolar
i suffer from perseverance i'm severely
schizophrenic
i'm dyslexic
i have psychosis um
what do you put a boyfriend through what
does a relationship with queen look like
would you say you have psychosis and
schizophrenia there's chill we [ __ ]
rise
right now that's what i'm looking for is
someone just to talk to it's all about
sex all right but you don't want me that
money
if you trying to chill i'd be friends
i'm down with that because that's what i
need
but as far as the [ __ ] all in my
face telling me what i'm doing what i'm
not going to do
and you haven't done anything to cater
to me or
i feel like you're abusing the role that
i'm giving you
you understand like it's a pleasure to
be in a room with me
just off of who i am how good of a
person how
loyal i'm loyal to [ __ ] that i
could arrive
[ __ ] i could have you know
man [ __ ] you like let me get all this
let me run all that
[ __ ] owe me twelve hundred
dollars three hundred dollars two
hundred dollars
and i just counted as a loss because i
know if i'll go
try to get that [ __ ] i'm gonna end up
killing somebody and i'm not trying to
do that
like i get so angry that i scare myself
i don't put my hands on people but like
someone puts their hands on me
i'm ahead of my business but no one
takes me
only because of who i am like you can't
disclose me and say you can't say
anything or speak negatively against me
unless you're making it up or you just
hate it
do you feel like you're misunderstood by
most people yeah but
i'm
genuinely right unapologetically i'm not
part of doing
myself i'm blunt sometimes
i can read minds kind of like if you
look at me my eyes
i can hear things that are going through
your head um
i can hear your thoughts your necks move
like i can hear
things i can hear conversations and it's
weird
but it's real and some people suffer
from you know oh yeah
it's crazy but i'm you wouldn't know you
wouldn't know that i
i can do all these things but i can
but i'm not gonna sit here and tell you
everything i hear what you saying but i
hear it
i just throw it to the wind because i
hear [ __ ] every day
and it's not just because i'm high it
i'm i
take medicine i'm about to start
something called cap lighter i'm trying
to see if i can get on that
um take the voices out i hear everything
to me i think mental health is the big
issue not drugs
well i'm on like six seven eight
meditations
um but i'm not anything right now
it's only smoking so when i get outside
you know i got to take a little second
like calm down
are you hoping that one day maybe some
one of your some guy pulls up and
takes you away from this life you know i
want to take my own stuff away good for
you
i'm just opening that what do you say is
the most
important thing you've learned in your
22 years
everything isn't what it seems
don't give your last a [ __ ] that
wouldn't give you a penny
don't put your all into a [ __ ]
that you
probably won't know a day or two from
now um
stay in your comfort zone you're not
comfortable don't go
i'm learning i made mistakes still
and i and like when you were younger you
made mistakes you've been through [ __ ]
and
[Music]
you were able to learn from me so now as
you're older you can be like yeah like i
did that [ __ ]
but me as only being 22 i still got to
go through that [ __ ] every day
but by the time i'm 34 i'm like damn
we did that
what are what are some of the biggest
mistakes you've made
um you've all made mistakes letting them
have a good thing
and they can talk to me type of way
little [ __ ] then they can come
in my
vicinity or be around me for three
minutes and thinking of running my life
when they help me do [ __ ] letting the
[ __ ]
eat before i do you understand
like i'm making the money but you eating
off me you take
all the money oh yeah i got you okay but
i haven't been through a lot of
[ __ ] trying to pay me since
i've been out here
but it's the thing uh okay you see me
walking hey you gotta get in the car
i get a car you driving down a block you
tell me it's gonna work
i'm not a hoe i'm a girl who needs money
right now and i'm selling like [ __ ] i'm
more like
a sugar baby or like escorting or
something
i'm not trying to be cold outside but as
naked i don't like being close because
i'm outside cold i have a hoodie on
some sweats or some leggings hey uncover
a little bit okay well when it gets cold
i'm gonna put it back on
like it's more if you want it
get it if you say oh well i don't know
if i want this
you might be missing out on something
big i just let it go
so you've had a tent before um i had one
in north carolina and that's how i ended
up starting i'm quiet
i'm not people that i do like i need
like a scout
not a scout but [ __ ] said that
he want to hang out with me or
he want to make money with me i hang out
with him for a little bit once i see you
ain't online
i'm going to my business so it's like
you can't help me succeed you can't even
help me
have a place to shower you can't even
help me have a place to lay my head you
can't
help me get a drink from the store
but as soon as it's time for me to get
some work i'm bringing you money for the
work
you can help me with that yeah so
[Music]
what's your biggest regret
[Music]
letting someone had complete
control over my life letting someone
put me down so much that i forgot who i
was
but now i'm finding who i am again and
i'm not losing them
a little bit harder all right queen
thank you so much for
talking with me yeah queen slim slam the
reaper
you have no you have several names queen
and then slim
but um it's slim reaper
like you can take my number out
write it down all right great job thank
you so much